I think the symbol of taking down the
flag would be a great step forward I
take this position that the federal
government really has no role in
determining what the state I'm not a
South Carolinian
and and I think this is a decision in
South Carolina I don't personally
display it anywhere so it's not an issue
for me and so that's an issue for the
people of South Carolina do you display
it in fact it's somebody came to
Arkansas and told us what to do with our
flag we tell them where to put the pole
I agreed that we need to be looking at
these issues as ways to bring the
country together
well at the end of the day is time for
people in South Carolina the Reeve is
that that decision would be fine with me
but this is part of who we are
you